[Musica]
ora che se sei chili skin funzionasse in
una certa maniera ti sei vedrebbe sotto
scherzando ti pare prega tutti ragazzi
prelato mettano rifacciamo delle ragazze
benvenuti visto vedetelo valigia
iniziamo con giulia allora volevo fare
una cosa molto simpatica volevo giocare
a port knight congiure voi costringerlo
a giocare sai cosa e fornai morta è
questa roba qua no non è questo
l'aspetto che questo porti nightcats
scusatemi ma la mia maglietta e
fluorescens sport nel green screen soul
cristina sport live eccolo queste forme
ed allora ci sono queste persone che
riveste qua quelle che stanno soldato ha
bocciato perché fanno fuori altre
persone l'obiettivo di questo gioco è
rimanere l'ultima in vita sono cento dei
rimanerne soltanto uno cioè il mio
personaggio si possibilmente ad essere
di vado su gioca ma nel vuoi spiegare
aspetta che vai un gioca come lo spiego
quando tu mi ricordo i tasti non le so
neanch'io
no no no allora speck e te spiego devi
ammazzare tutti però non con sia partiti
stai tranquilla sarobi presto vai avanti
avanti proprio avanti vai verso le armi
ok ok per questi anni dalla prendi
l'arma ci vai vicino e la prende in
automatico io punterei più a destra
destra destra vedi che c'è stata a
destra adesso proteste con gli eventi
perché ci diventare le case perché
dentro le case ci sono le armi va bene
se ti va bene ti ammazza nessun server
attente che si iscrivono alla vicina a
porta a porta
la porta a sinistra ma non ci vedo
niente la porta aprila con l'aics questa
ex questa brava entra non me non vedo in
ogni stagione ufficiale singolo
ammazzato luca piana
tokyo della mia luca ok non si fa così
stupida rifà magari famo ma chi è questo
e luca con il tasto con cui ha aperto la
porta prendi anche le armi
bene come ha fatto prendere lo sapeva
che stava per rientrare sulla ca
bravissimi aiutami come si fa mi aspetto
che ci sta gente c'è paura quale l'arma
quello dell arma sequel e arnone è un
deltaplanista bravo le crete 10 maggio e
giugno ma poi tra una tomaia è il buco
julian frigo julian frigo quello ma
questo colpiva indietro di tutta l'arma
per sparare a scassinare pd che non
riesce dopo la visuale di dove volerà
che sta valutando un pasto questo come
faccio a girarmi indietro a gironi la
visuale gira tu vai vai io giro la
visuale basta ok premiarmi prendiamo che
adesso devi solo equipaggio per aiutami
maio acqui peggiori con ok aveva il
nuovo tomb raider
bene adesso tu puoi accusare non riesco
a girare la visual a genero iera l'acino
io la visuale adesso salta fuori salta
fuori che ora diverso come sale doveri
verso qua esalta che conosco molto bene
adesso ci stai no vai avanti ma che
becchi una persona così questo tasto qui
non sparare anche insieme alla norma.la
riso con quello solo quel coro quello
che mi stai lasciando andare nelle
fratte perché c'è della gente nelle però
stiamo qua villa borghese
se vedi qualcuno è quello che si aspetta
dove io vi va avanti con rigori sicuro
rigorini con l'esclusiva vailatti
costruttori siate punta piano piano ma
diritto allo studio
ma vai vittoria ha visto sia città e li
vai avanti avanti dicono mi fai qua qua
e ti giri e va avanti altrimenti avanti
ora ti giri dove vai avanti ma io vai
avanti e basta i perni politico fermati
davanti basta avanti passati per mi
comprava anche il bacio davanti basta
dalla sparata giulia 6 volta giugno
e difficile sei stato tu a fare noi
dobbiamo riuscire che è l'angelo della
morte
questo è un altro guarda poi scommette
che ho capito come sentiamo danno però
si mira la gente è come se mi devi
puntarli non sai come si muove la
visuale sa come finirà la gente come
simile alla gente con questo vigilia
visuale vai dove il mirino puntanti se
poi schiaccia ma è difficili se non è
semplice portare anche sto andando a
fosso grande poi prende quello che vuoi
per avanti adesso parto ma non ce
l'avrai e quindi che hanno a presentare
tutti vogliono uccidermi e tutti quanti
vogliono uccidere per tutti tu vuoi
uccidere anche tutti ok ok piano qui c'è
una casta ci venga e non un l'avaya
vicino a casa e dispiacere girati verso
la cassa con la visuale girati colavita
tunnel veri promotori brava lo scrutino
lo prendi lo scudo nera da brava brava
brava lo prendi con l'attacco è ok ora
in un'arca aiuti ai una cappa comunque
allora ti faccio vedere tu poniamo che
questo che questo comodino sia una
persona io ho vista una cosa non mano a
piazza
vai avanti in avanti e ci arrivi di qua
e mi fa il giro di far giro di una parte
9 fame del apprende vai dritto salta
salta salute salta al comodino
stiamo gesù cristo dove siamo e siamo
esaltati troppo aspetto che noi
scendiamo e riuniamo e non ho mai povero
chiamati un pelino più avanti che così
capiscono la mamma poi bene così va bene
perché stiamo solo facendo dell'ultimi
normalissimo pensate ma basta andrà a
lei c'è un altro scudo tra l'altro poi
chissenefrega abbiamo era tanto non è
che ci aiuta
corri ma scusami dove stava sto
disgraziato ora che fa il tifo
giulia ben più forte il tuo cane
scusami eh però non è giusto così ne è
venuto mai visto quello sì giulia si
potevamo giocare a pacman vai giulia che
la loro brava giulia questa la palla
roteante questo acqua trattata a cochi e
se va bene vorrei che ce n'è stata
un'altra giunta con questa qua arrivi
davanti ci si deve quindi una cosa molto
viva ragazzi non pensavo di vedere
questa cosa per il team va bene abbiamo
trovato il gioco di giulia correre a
casa giulia per la casa viene fuori la
casa alla casa la casta la casta la
canta ti spara non salta è brava sata e
33 33
ma c'è qualcuno e spero di no chi è devo
fare la lavatrice c'è il green screen
hai visto è stato marco hai trovato la
non al colo non mi riconosco l'arco rose
domini col tasto destro e poi sparì e
spara un portiere fortissimo trend per
di me senti rumori che ti do una mano si
12 esito neppure 220 rumori e jego
leotta spara ad ora c'è qualcuno lì
dietro c'è qualcuno eccoli lì dietro la
finestra brava giulia
ciao pirla tipo bravo bravo perché siamo
nati via joystiq rivia joystick e se
bravissimo romagna che è sciolta la
ninja mamma mia gioia
tieni joystick così e non schiacci
niente non schiacci niente tv sono così
e io tengo così e così ma che giochi ii
rata sto giocando io
eccoli lì dietro la finestra o moriremo
ma chi se ne frega ormai morti con amore
nostro onore siamo morti giulia hard
parte eccolo lì col bayern
via via via via non ammazzarlo
ci credo cioè mi colpì giulia
va beh non importa non esporta sei stata
molto breve sei stata molto brava brava
proprio lei è bravissima incredibile
dobbiamo guardare i ragazzi io si guarda
la io ringrazio giulia dopo questa età
non è finito il gioco di cam e adesso
che hanno giocato a porta a porta a
porta e dovetti fare un altro gioco mai
spiega male come avete trovato le armi
come trovate le armi su forza doveva
andare sotto al mio ultimo video di
youtube della mia canzone sempre bene
trovare degli easter egg che sono 7 vi
dico già questa volta che compongono una
parola
vediamo se riuscite a capire qual è la
parola composta da questi tetti easter
egg quello che ha detto lei ci sono
sette opere video sogni watch una
lettera e queste uova compongono una
parola quale ninja
no non lo sai che mi a provocarla
cercarle va bene io vi ringrazio per la
visione di questo video ringrazio giulia
per assieme randy d'achille
noi ci rivediamo in un prossimo episodio
passate da video di julian descrizione è
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
beh ragazzi
[Musica]